do you regret buying your home yes Sam
what's up what's going on let me pull up
some of our documents I'm in Austin
still and what's what's what's a with
the world like in Austin right now
crazy everything's crazy I don't think
it's as bad as San Francisco but the
world is crazy I I decided to we got a
new office down here and so I've rented
a house to see everyone and it's cool
Austin's a great city what do you thinks
gonna happen to San Francisco do you
think it's gonna like is this gonna be
the end of San Francisco being like the
place I think so yeah
I think so for a couple reasons you know
right now I'm selling my house yeah so
say you're your house looks different
you're decorating it to sell aren't you
yeah I am trying to sell my house right
now so it's about to go up for sale and
I'm trying to move to the suburbs of the
Bay Area but and so right now because
I'm doing that I'm in the middle of the
market and listening to people I'm
securing you know what are they what's
like a mic is the market hot to sell am
I gonna get a good price when I try to
go look for something else is there a
lot of stuff available or is it a
bidding war and you know just like you
would expect there's sort of a you know
a flight to the flight to space right
now and not like the space expand I'm
talking about like physical house space
people in the urbanisation yeah do
religious people are leaving cities the
leaving San Francisco for sure so a lot
of people were in San Francisco were
here because of the career opportunities
and now that the tech companies are
saying you know either we are already
remote or we're going remote or way more
remote friendly and your work from home
for the server foreseeable future here
there's basically no the premium the
extreme premium I mean like one bedroom
for four grand a month
two bedrooms six grand a month you know
type of rents to be in the city and so
like you know when a when a studio condo
is a million dollars in the city you
know if you don't have to pay that
you're not going to and so people want
space people want more affordability and
people want to be away from like a whole
bunch of other people from this virus
and so
that is driving a lot of people out of
the cities now some people say oh that's
just temporary personally I don't think
so I don't think you can put the genie
back in the bottle
once the companies start letting you be
removed and it doesn't matter where
you're physically located why would you
live in a more expensive area only if
that lifestyle really appeals to you
which it will for like twenty something
year olds right to be in cities but
right now you get the twenty something
year olds and the 30 something year olds
because the 30 something year olds are
there for their career and that's gonna
go away I feel like I've been in Austin
for a week now I'm gonna stay for
another week maybe I'll stay one more
week down here it is definitely happier
like the way of life like it for me and
for many others I understand why you'd
happier here like dude my new house I
got I got a pool I'm like a swimming
pool like what is this this is amazing
that makes me happy just looking at the
swimming pool I like it too my thing
though is I miss San Francisco I want to
come back I do miss a little bit of a
struggle I also miss the people I hate
the people and a dangerous San Francisco
has like actual you know real problems
with crime and homelessness and stuff
like that I don't think anybody wants
that and where they're living it I think
you know there's part of it that's the
energy of the city
I love being New York I love being at
emphasis come around all these
energizing interesting ambitious people
a bunch of single people but then
there's just like crime and homelessness
and like extreme expenses that put a
burden on you and I think that's nobody
likes that I almost feel like not a real
way but just because I can't think of a
better word a little homeless where I'm
like well where the [__] is my place now
like where's my like you know yeah you
and I we're not quite similar you've
done it more than I have but me too and
a lesser extent I've lived in many
different cities and I finally felt like
I had a home in San Francisco and now
I'm like [__] like it's wait it's like
damn it's way different and so I'm I'm
pretty sad about it to be honest like
I've been like depressed over it I'm
also sad obviously about all the other
shit's going on is it are you seeing
unrest and protesting and looting where
you live
I'm seeing it because I'm just glued to
Twitter and me too you know I'm just
scrolling and I can't believe my eyes
and it is it so sad there's so many
different things going on at the same
time and then the the shitty part about
that to me
is that everybody pulls a different
meaning away from it so like if you're
biased going in is you know did you know
if you're a racist in one way you're
going to look at this and say oh man
they're rooting and they're looting and
rioting and this is awful what are those
small business owners do why are they
why are they getting the store smashed
and then if you're somebody else and
you're looking at this you're like dude
people are sick of it they've hit their
breaking point because it's been going
on for so long this police brutality and
I totally understand what's going on and
then other people are looking at it and
they're sort of like hey what's like why
are these other malicious groups kind of
hijacking the movement and just inciting
violence and you know antifa or some
people believe you know Russia China
whoever it is who's dropping these
pallets of bricks off trying to bait
people into violence and you know some
people just rying to make the world burn
and so there's all these things mixed
together and I think whoever you are
you're gonna select the evidence that
supports your feeling and you're just
gonna get stronger you're just gonna see
more evidence towards your view and it's
gonna make people more divided
my friend shared something and it was
like four circles and it was like I'm
pissed off about the racism in our
countries and black lives matter black
lives matters has a point I'm pissed off
that businesses are getting ruined this
is not the right way to do it
I'm pissed off as the police because I
think most of them are good but a few
bad cops ruined [__] for everyone and
then I forget the fourth one and then it
was like at the center all the circles
had a little bit of everything and like
you can be here I was like that's how I
feel I'm angry at it's sad circle I
don't know what the fourth one was let's
see it was really great though did
usually happy to see this girl I don't
see that but no that explains like
exactly how I feel you know and how many
people feel and you know I think it's
really great you know there's a whole
bunch of things that that you hear you
learn from these experiences where
you're like oh you know that is a sort
of a nugget of wisdom or and a bit of
empathy that I didn't have before and so
you know when you see people that are
you know one great quote I saw was when
you have a thousand good cops and ten
bad cops but the good cops don't police
the bad cops
thousands and ten bad cops and you know
I believe that and then that sort of
applies to my life too like in what
anytime I sort of stand by and do
nothing well injustice is happening that
makes me sort of complicit in my own way
right and you know I think about little
minor examples of that in my own life
and then it was George Floyd's George
George Floyd's death was murder and the
police should be held responsible I
think most cops are good but police
departments are corrupt and there are
some bad cops
looting businesses and destroying
properties in morale it hurts the cause
I empathize and I agree with black five
matter protester and believe in then the
right to be heard and then right in the
middle was like I am here and this is
sad right yeah it's really crazy and I
know people don't listen Spock has to
hear like you know talks about
socio-economic issues and racism and
whatnot but you know this I think
affects everybody is very different than
anything that's happened in my lifetime
where you have riots breaking out across
the nation all simultaneously and things
really do feel like they've hit a
breaking point for many reasons I think
also the fact that people were picked up
at home for the last three months I
don't think that helps necessarily
because that's a sort of a bunch of a
bunch of you know just water boiling
over you know at a certain point as well
I agree I saw I agree I don't even love
discussing this stuff as I think about
it a lot and I also tend to like they
talk about the positive but let me bring
something up that I don't think I have
bring up brought up and I want to hear
your opinion so I don't this doesn't
matter and it doesn't change I don't
think it should like validate or just
not about validate anything I say so
like my wife's black my family's black
I'll have black children and this was
the first time or half partially black
children this was the first time that I
was at my house with Sarah my wife and
like she broke down she was like I don't
I don't know how she's like I don't know
where I fit in on this because she's
like a successful black woman she's a
guy haven't had a lot of racist stuff
happened to me or if any like I yeah and
it was and she's like but I yeah it was
it was it was just a total mind [__]
because I'm like [__] what am I supposed
to how am I supposed to I don't I don't
know what to feel
I didn't I was like I don't I don't know
what to do and it was incredibly
exhausting do you you you're Indian do
you consider yourself white or not white
what definitely considered was of white
and nor does anyone who sees me thinks
I'm white but well I don't know like how
but I get what you mean in the sense of
like in some ways like do you feel that
you're privileged or prejudiced against
I think that's a different way of
looking at it and like you know my
sister so we I was born in Tulsa
Oklahoma which is like you know not the
most open-minded and racially friendly
place and so my sister when she was in
kindergarten you know students would
would draw a picture of a pig and then
write her name on it and cover the body
and brown mud and then they would give
it to the teacher and the teacher laughs
my sister who always remembers this like
she was I don't know six years old and
she vividly remembers the teacher sort
of looking at this and laughing and
saying no no no put it away but like
being you know involved in it and I
never I don't understand that what's the
pig have to do is that because just like
a brown brown dirty in the mud you know
that sort of thing and and you know I
remember you know when she went to my
mom it was like why can't be we'd be
white aside to thing where's like you
know asking questions as a kid just
trying to understand why am i different
what does that mean why do other people
think were worse than them that sort of
thing I personally never experienced
that cuz I had luckily moved out of
Oklahoma when I was really young and
went to different places where it was it
was less so or just got lucky and sort
of my experiences around who I was
around but I guess I would say like you
know when 9/11 happened you know they're
not fun to be a brown guy in are you are
you any religion a Muslim no under and
they just but I wouldn't even do yeah
would be Hindu but you know just that's
typically what most any people are but
yeah you know I'm not religious but you
know I do grow a beard pretty quick and
so like yeah you know like when you go
to the airport I don't think you think
about how do I look today whereas I
think about that so I'm like look I'm
not trying to get hassled for no reason
here's let me shave before I get on this
flight or like you know I had friends
who like are Muslim who had like key
their house keys take it away from them
in TSA because it was like this is you
know potentially a dangerous thing and
then like this is my apartment
how does that make you feel so the fact
that you have to shave are you
angry or you wait where do you what's
that make you feel like I'm not angry
about it you know I I sort of have this
opinion that my Bible my personal
philosophy if you were going to boil it
down to any one thing is the only thing
you have control over is your attitude
towards the present moment and so so
that's empowering and disempowering
right so it's disempowering because it's
like [__] I can't control anything
that's going on I can't control how
other people feel how they're gonna act
I can't control the results I'm gonna
get in my life but it's empowering it's
like the one thing I control is my
attitude towards the moment so that sort
of is a superpower because then no
matter what the situation is no matter
what the moment is I can decide what my
attitude about it is gonna be so for
example when something shitty happens to
me someone says something shitty or you
know I you know get that extra I sort of
hate coming to this room while I go
through TSA clearance you know the
meaning I put on that is of my choosing
and if I put the meaning of it that you
know I'm less than I'm being wronged
that doesn't help me it makes me feel
like [__] and so I just decide not to
feel that way but I know that like on
the grand scheme of things I get off
pretty light it's very different than
never feeling safe you know going for a
jog in your neighborhood or something
like that I think you know there's
levels to it and I haven't experienced
those levels where it would be very very
challenging to put a positive meaning on
what's going on yeah it's a it's just a
confusing time because you feel so many
different emotions and some of them are
opposite and I had to like talk to the
whole company today which were small
let's say 20 or 30 people and I was like
I don't know what to say other than a
few guys like ever feel out of place
somewhere like our company we're gonna
we're gonna make you feel safe like
we'll hire all types of people we like I
wasn't sure if that felt like weak or
like like oh like like a barely anything
I was like I don't know what I was like
I don't know how to [__] handle this
other than you're safe here
but yeah you know I think that's the
right approach because it's not about
having the answer or the wisdom or the
most heartfelt thing and the best speech
but like
I think it is important if you're the
leader to show up as a decent human
being in that moment just say look I
understand I'm also feeling this crazy
mix of emotions I just want to do my
best with this anything you know we're
gonna we're gonna try to do our best at
this I think it goes a long way to just
be a decent person and try to be present
and visible there versus kind of shying
away from it which is what a lot of
people do yeah it's crazy and I have a
feeling once I have children my opinions
gonna change a lot like or not my
opinion but my I think I'll learn a lot
yeah like having black kids or part
black kids I think well I'll maybe I'll
see something that I didn't previously
see and one more thing which you know we
can cut all this out if people tell us
later hey you shouldn't talked about
this on the pot but did you watch The
Trevor Noah thing that's posted on
YouTube or whatever I did not I'm
typically not a fan of his I think that
a lot of times he says is the wrong take
so I I tend to avoid him but I would
watch it if you suggest it avoid him cuz
he I don't think he's that funny but I
did watch this thing and you know he
brings up like what's going on he's like
yeah a lot of people are looking at
what's going on and saying well this
isn't right either right of course
police should not murder citizens that's
wrong but also rioting and looting and
destroying things is also not right and
what his point was which I think made me
better understand what was going on his
point was like you got to think about
this what is society you know a society
is essentially a contract it is an
agreement amongst a group of people up
here's what's right and wrong of how
we're gonna act here's the behaviors
that are tolerated here's the babes that
are not tolerate he goes so what you're
saying is that one side of a contract
you know if we're if we go into a
contract together and you're just
breaching your side of the contract
regularly and without recourse and I
just see wow this guy just keeps
breaching his side of the contract then
I also have no no desire or incentive to
uphold my side of the contract he goes
you'll see somebody that's homeless and
you know they don't go and just murder
necessarily because because they're in a
bad position they say look these are the
rules of the game I'm losing in the
current game or
have not been able to sort of get to an
advantage position in this game but like
I still respect that we're in a game
together and there are rules of this
game he goes what you're seeing now is
that a group of people you know black
people in America feel like the contract
has just been breached over and over and
over again where they're you know
unnecessary and unjust violence against
us and so now we're gonna breach the
contract too and we're gonna sort of
make it very known what it feels like
when the contract is being breached for
apparently no reason and it doesn't seem
like a positive thing and so that made
me look at you know when somebody is
either protesting whether it's
peacefully or not peacefully when
somebody's rioting and they're creating
a sort of unsafe environment for all
it's sort of I don't know sort of
explained to me why somebody would
behave that way it's because if you feel
like the other party is just turned
breached the contract and then there's
no recourse then it's like I'm gonna
terminally breach the contract and and
we'll see we'll see how it feels and now
both sides feel what it's like when the
societal contract gets totally breached
I definitely feel the tension I feel it
I feel it definitely feels like like
almost like the end of the world
a little bit it's like there's it's like
a small it's like in the same way having
a new puppy is just like a small taste
of having a baby it's like that's how I
feel right now like I'm like it's like
the world if like everything that I
believed in is gonna come to an end it's
gonna take a little a little like this
right you know it's there every sad
story there's also an inspiring story
where people are you know waking up the
next day and going and cleaning up the
city and people standing together and
you know I think there's a lot of really
positive things going on too and I think
that's the you know that's the silver
lining or that's the other side of the
coin here where is progress being made
and there's this guy there's this guy
he's a listener I actually forget his
name I think his name is Zach I told you
about him he's from Utah he called me
the other he calls me like every week
like hey you gonna come to Utah now
you're gonna come to you did he call you
y'all talking about he calls me every
week and he called me like a Sunday ago
when there's all this Corona thing was
go like it was like bad Corona and I
just got some bad news and he called me
I was like quick [__] call me or like
I like I lost my temper with them so
first of all if you're listening guy
forget your name but my apologies you
just caught me at a bad time he's
[__] calling me and I was so angry
about the world and so anyway he was
calling me about coming to Utah I'm like
maybe I need to get out to Utah right
now so a guy like I feel like I'm afraid
to be around the world at the moment so
maybe I'll go out there let me ask you a
question real quick and I mean we don't
have to owe you you bought your house so
your house is in a you could say where
you live if you want but we'll say it's
a nice neighborhood that still has some
issues in San Francisco it's like I
would say one of the less nice
neighborhoods I'm just going over all
but it's still desirable because it's
like in the hipster area
do you regret buying your home yes do
you as your what you can want to say
what your rights is is that your new
house or not yeah sure so the new house
front is seven grand a monk and was that
less than your mortgage
yeah it's less overall because with the
house you have you know property tax you
have your mortgage and then you have
like you know sort of the house
maintenance issues that come up over
time that you know we're just
miscellaneous things do you think you'll
make it a bit money a little bit less
but similar you think you're gonna make
any money off of this deal not really
and that's good you know because selling
house has a lot of fees so like you know
when you buy a house if you want to sell
it the next day you basically need to
sell it for 5% more just with the broker
fees and then there's like the transfer
tax and then there's you know all the
staging costs you know it's gonna cost
us 15 grand to stage the place and fix
up the paint and the you know little
scuffs and scratches that we've had
along the way and then our you know we
didn't take care of a long as good as we
should have so we gotta get a landscaper
so there's all these costs of selling so
it's gonna come out that you broke even
any wood for free or as they come out
that you just lived for a crate or
whatever the yeah I lived for I lived it
basically about what I could have lived
renting it or maybe a little bit ahead
we'll see how it Nets out like it's
unknown right like with the cove it and
stuff like we don't even know you know
for somebody to come do an open house
tourists like a lot of friction now it's
like wear your mask signed this waiver
blah blah blah so I don't know where
it's gonna sell for but the reason I
regret it is not because of any of that
you know right before I bought the house
like I had been house hunting and like a
week before I was hanging out with soui
Antilles you know one
times wealthier than I am and I asked
him I said do you own your place and I
was hanging out at his house he says no
don't you own like you know just the
most baller house here because you could
and he was like oh yeah no I like the
you know I like to flex a bit of renting
blah blah and I was like mmm seems like
he just kind of didn't give me the full
answer there so I asked him it again at
the very end of walk even want to make
you feel bad
yeah talking about uber and I was like
so if you were me would you buy he goes
no I hope wait why and he goes he goes
really simple he's like I just think I
can get a better cap rate and better
return on my money essentially doing
other things than buying a home so like
you know you put your down payment down
20% your home in our case 25% and that
money sits in your home and it's
appreciating at the rate of your home
appreciation which is like you know
varies resonated well I think yeah
historically across all homes I think
it's 3% yeah exactly the San Francisco
did a lot better during a certain era
where was like 10-15 percent a year but
his point was basically like yeah like I
know that my if I take all my options
for how to deploy a dollar you know
stock market I can expect about a 7%
return and you know I can do private you
know startup investing I can do private
equity I can put my money with hedge
fund I could do multi find real estate
there's like all these things I can do
putting it into a down payment of a
house is not the best way and on top of
that it doesn't spit off any cash flow
so like if I do if I just buy a home and
I rent it out to someone I get the
appreciation of a home plus I get the
cash flow every month we're trying to
say this to everyone and they hate
hearing it and I understand why they
hate hearing it but I think buying how
in our in our in Austin all of our staff
buys homes
and I'm like look don't tell me you're
buying this house because it's a good
investment tell me you're buying this
house because you want to like when I
bought my stake last night I didn't
think that this $30.00 is a good
investment I did it because I thought
why it's not a financial investment but
a good investment like it made me happy
I wanted it I work hard so I can have
things I want so if you're so like if
you buy your house don't tell me you're
doing it because it's you're just
throwing away money on rent right tell
me you're doing it because it's gonna
make you happy or because you want to
because that is a good reason but to say
that it's an investment that's [__]
you could say that it's a great way to
preserve wealth but it absolutely in
most cases is not a great way to make
them well
right yeah exactly yeah and I don't
blame anybody who thinks that I thought
that five seven years ago I would have
also said it isn't renting like flushing
money down the toilet and if you buy
your home you have equity blah blah blah
and I learned pretty quickly first
person I talked to that were like no
that's not exactly how it works so yeah
if you haven't gone down that rabbit
hole go down the RAM hole because they
sort of American dream of like own your
own home with your you know your white
picket fence in your backyard that is
pretty silly and yeah it also made a lot
more sense with the ratio of income to
housing prices was closer than it is now
now it's significantly different out of
that and you face like you know risk
right like when I'm in my home and now
boom remote work is on the rise being in
a city is not not the thing anymore it's
like oh [__] you know people take it for
granted that these things just sort of
go up and you know you're one shift away
you know as soon as Elon Musk can make
the Hyperloop work where I can commute
long distances in like 20 minutes or
less then people are gonna want to go
live further away have way more you know
space resources whatnot and not want to
be impacted you know like I started
eating into a city a lot of people will
choose that and so you're one
technological shift or one policy shift
or in this case one policy plus
biological you know terror away from not
wanting people not wanting to be in a
certain type of real estate class like
the way a family in real estate is now
struggling because of because of what's
going on you get a whole lot of
unemployment and now people can't pay
the rent and you know every month rents
are dropping it was like 99% of people
pay their rent last month on the
multifamily stuff that I read ninety
percent of people are paying their rent
and if that dips below you know a
certain number maybe it's 82 percent or
whatever it is
now all sudden you're underwater in a
multi-family real estate the way that I
like to live because so I've been an
entrepreneur since I was 16 making money
on my own not necessarily all the time a
lot of a lot of money but like having to
like go out and hunt and kill each week
and I like am allergic to like really
big purchases and I'm allergic to
getting locked into stuff and I actually
think that that me being allergic to
that has actually hurt me I think that
had I increased my overhead on some
things my overheads really cheap I had I
increased my overhead I actually
would have worked harder to like have to
like fulfill that overhead but now I
mean if I don't work for many for very
long I don't even know how long maybe
forever
I'm fine and I just prefer to be on that
defense cockroaches and putting you know
in San Francisco you got to put them
three or four hundred thousand dollars
on home I'm like a [__] I don't wanna
that's scary I don't want to do that you
know what I mean yeah and so I've never
had the courage to do it okay um a
couple things I thought were interesting
[Music]
one
you usually posted something about this
thing called mode points what is that me
yeah did you post something about mow
point no what is no points it's just I
thought it's your friend who was doing
it it's basically like oh my friend yet
no yes
he just launched it yeah Moe my friend
Moe okay so what it is is yeah I was
like what the heck I didn't even
remember the name my friend Moe helps
people with points that's funny I love
that we're talking about so Moe points
so Moe it's my friend Moe him and Ramone
grew up together in most from
Afghanistan by way of where's Ramon from
Netherlands and then moved here and they
used to have a business it's shut down
now so I could talk about it where they
would buy and sell airline points and he
became an expert on how to maximize
points and so I'm getting into this now
and so for example if there's all these
ways that you can like inter spending
money on advertising on this and that
you can maximize your points and fly for
free forever for years and so he would
teach me how to do it myself and I was
like whoa turn this into a course and so
that's what it is let's let's pick them
out though is it moe points comm moe
points calm yeah I checked it out
because I was pretty interested in this
like in the same way that you want like
a tax guy to help you save money on the
back end you know whenever you do likes
pretty significant credit card spending
and a lot of times if you own your own
business you can rack up a lot of
spending on cards I hate going and
figuring this stuff out I just feel like
it's a waste of my brain and it's a
waste of my time to go or like optimize
my spending and buy points so I can
travel free and look all this stuff but
I think no it's valuable and
I was hoping to get like what's the
shortcut what's the like you know either
you do it for me or like what's the
80/20 give me the few things I can do
that will give me the highest return on
my time and effort because I know I'm
sort of wasting this opportunity and I
don't want to go become an expert in the
stuff but if you're an expert fantastic
so I signed up for it oh great I make
sure he knows so you know points are
interesting I just got into him recently
so I earn maybe 300,000 to 400,000
points a month and that translates to 1%
of that in cash value so if I spent a
million dollars a year on through my
credit card which sounds like a lot if
you're just an individual and that is a
lot if you're an individual but your
business that's nothing I get $100,000
cash back now here's the cool things
that cash fact in most cases is tax-free
so in if you live in San Francisco
that's the equivalent of getting a
salary of 180 grand or yeah and so it's
great and so I've actually met some
entrepreneurs who I think you can get up
to three hundred sixty thousand dollars
some of the Countians gonna like tweet
at me and say I got it wrong but I'm
almost positive and it's controversial
I'm almost up to 350 thousand dollars in
cash back and so I know this one lady
who's got this flour company and she
gets three hundred fifty thousand
dollars in cash back income a year yeah
that's great I have a friend who he he
basically negotiate with his investors
he's like I'd like to pay the AWS bill
from a company on my personal credit
card and so he earned like whatever Amex
double black platinum gold whatever it
is like the highest tier for life
because they were spending like you know
three million a month on AWS but they
crazy and so like he's like oh if I ever
want to fly I fly first-class now I get
like three eccrine odds I get freed this
I get three that because that's the
person like the highest tier of Amex and
he's like yeah I got lifetime because
during my company I just asked can I
just put this on this card and keep that
you know tied to my name and and so and
so that's what Moe's trying to do now
it's just like a course and hand
hand-to-hand combat like consultation we
try to help people but that is kind of
interesting too like logged into a
portal and
like technology and it does it for you
that is pretty amazing and and your
transaction fee is either upfront fee or
you take you skim a little that is
incredibly interesting I like it okay so
have another random idea I want to talk
about so I have a friend shout-out to my
friend Mike who he went to Duke where I
went to school he was Duke best football
player at the time like he was like I
think he led the nation in tackles or
something like that she's an amazing
linebacker was football player goes he's
a little undersized but he gets drafted
or he gets a tryout with it with a
couple teams and he ended up getting cut
after a year I think from the
Indianapolis Colts and that sort of like
the end of his football career but he
built a ton of connections and still has
connections with athletes in the NBA and
NFL so I was talking to him about it I
was like you know what problems these
guys have what stuff are they trying to
do because these are often a class of
people who have a lot of money I have
specific problems to like people with
money fame and specific lifestyle what
are some ideas that you know problems
that they had that I've just never seen
but I could solve because I understand
them and so one of the things he had
mentioned not even has a problem but I
was like asking how they did it was
every athlete or I should say every many
athletes start their own foundation or
charity you've probably seen this like
you know oh you know random
wide-receiver it's not just like the top
of the top it's like random I just yeah
I have a foundation back in my CD it's
for kids for you blah blah blah kids and
books it's for Justin poor yet for year
one of my favorite fighters has one and
so I was wondering was it hey why do
they do this and then be like how do
they do this like could you build a
business around this and so on the y-you
know there's some interesting things and
again the accountants are gonna be sort
of out in full force correcting me on
this but it seems like basically the you
know there's some tax advantages to a
foundation in addition to like obviously
wanting to give back as often an
athlete's come from pretty rough you
know backgrounds and so they do feel
this pull okay I've made it I won the
lottery how do I get back so there's the
there's the emotional pole to give back
and create a foundation and then there's
the financial pull as well which is
there are some tax advantages to doing
the to doing it this way where you
basically are you're able to give and
you're able to give today
and reduce your taxable income and that
money goes to the foundation which can
then over time spend that money long
after your career is over even so you
can separate the the time of giving and
then the time of spending you can
separate the tax event from the giving
yeah that's got the name of it but you
and I have a friend who had a large exit
and what he did was he put away a
significant amount of money I think a
very significant amount of money at
least five it could be as high as ten he
put it into this charitable account and
over the next I'm gonna butcher this I
think over the next five years he has to
spend that on what's it called what's a
nonprofit called a 403 C five oh yeah
he's got a he's got a he's got to get
rid of it so whenever I see like a
missing charity I'm like hey guy cool
and there's other things like a DAF
which is a donor advised fund which is
what Jack Dorsey said I'm gonna give a
billion dollars away and he did it via a
DAF so this other ways but I guess but
my idea was cool so there's reasons a
Athletes one foundations they're clearly
doing this but I know athletes athletes
are not excited to go figure out the
paperwork to start a foundation to make
sure they're reporting on time all that
stuff so I was wondering is there a
stripe atlas for foundations is there a
push a button get your app you get your
foundation spun up without having to get
on the phone without having to print out
a piece of paper and go mail it some but
somewhere because I think you could
build a pretty nice but you know
potentially pretty lucrative
subscription business where you know
these foundations there's a spin up fee
and then there's an annual maintenance
basically to keep your foundation in
good standing I think there's a business
there so let's talk about Atlas for a
second so Atlas is a thing with stripe
and it's a click of a button set up in a
I'll see I think or do other stuff seek
or pins out speak or Borella why how
does that make money well it makes money
so it's strategic for striped because if
you're doing that you're probably gonna
stay in the stripe ecosystem so they're
like cool how do we get more customers
let's get new businesses to get created
and then bill your strengths so it's
kind of like when Facebook gives away
Internet to people who don't have the
internet it's like cool we'll give you
the Internet and guess what you're gonna
do the internet use Facebook so stripes
doing the same thing it's like how do
increase the rate of new startups
because in start-up stir who use a
stripe and then if they grow they grow
with us and fantastic we got them all
their young type of thing so then how
would this make money then what charity
they do charge a fee so like when I did
it I used ripe Atlas to spin on my
company and I think what it is a couple
hundred bucks but it's great it's like I
don't want to talk to a lawyer I trust
that this will this will get set up
properly if they do all the filing and
documentation they're just email me hey
here's your tax ID here's your entity
here's the Articles of formation etc and
so stripe Atlas was great took me three
weeks and I don't know two hundred
dollars or something like that and I got
my company set up why did she do a
sequel I did an LLC for me oh but if I
wanted to do a sequel but like if I was
gonna do a startup that was gonna erase
money I would do a c-corp and and I
would have used it for that let's talk
about the same amount Monday yeah
have you read this post no but it's the
same woman something I I have something
good that can piggyback off of it okay
you want to start with that you want me
to kind of know and I want you to start
is the Sam Altman who's the guy who runs
white Y Combinator or just run it
anymore actually but he was the
president of my Combinator and kind of
one of the you know more well-known guys
soca valley he put up this blog post
called idea generation and he said you
know one of the most common questions I
get is how do you get ideas for our new
startups a lot of it we want to do
startups but they don't quite know the
idea or they don't have a lot of
conviction in it
and he says something it really goes why
see once tried an experiment to fund
people who we thought would be good
founders but with no ideas you guys and
I think every company and this no idea
track failed and it turns out that
founders have a lot of ideas about
everything but like great founders
actually have a lot of ideas and if you
want to founder if you have a founder
who can't think of an idea they probably
shouldn't be a founder it's kind of
distant but then he's just explained art
so how do you get ideas for startups so
he says think number one you want to be
in the right environment so you want to
be around the right kind of people so he
said who are the right kind of people he
goes you want to be around people who
can have a good feel for the future they
will entertain improbable plans they're
optimistic and they're smart in a
creative way and he says they have high
idea flux which is you know pretty good
for our podcast like I consider both of
us idea machines and that's what he says
we calls idea flux so the rate of ideas
coming in
other body these sorts of people tend to
think without the constraints that most
people have they don't have a lot of
filters and they don't care too much
what other people think he says this is
important because the best ideas are
pretty fragile most people don't even
want to start talking about them because
they sound kind of silly up front and
like take the hustle for example we want
to be this big bad media company we're
gonna do an email newsletter and an
email newsletter actually sounded quite
silly to people who were traditionally
in media this was you know back if you
rewind several years so you want to be
around people who won't make you feel
stupid for mentioning a bad idea and
they certainly don't feel stupid when
they mentioned that ideas and he
basically says stay away from people who
are like the world has beaten them down
or they're the type that belittle your
ambitions and unfortunately this in most
of the world they hold on to the past
and and if you want to live in the
future you don't want to be around these
people and then he says okay so here's
the sort of next thing that would help
you get good idea so first let's be
around those types of people the second
is identify a tectonic shift that's
happening right now how is the world
changing in some fundamental way can you
identify the leading edge of that change
and the opportunity that unlocks it for
example mobile phone comes out 2007 2008
and then you get all these companies
like snapchat uber Airbnb etc that were
launched in that time on top of that
like core fundamental shift these up
when a big shift happens the big
companies usually get beat by fast
moving and focused startups so you want
to ask yourself a question like what's
something that's possible this year that
wasn't possible last year and pay
attention anytime something like that
comes up there's probably a lot of good
ideas in that space the last thing is if
you ever feel like something is like if
you can say the statement I'm sure this
is gonna happen I don't know if we'll be
the ones to do it that's a good sign
he's like uber was like this for me the
first time I used it it was clear I
wasn't gonna be hailing a cab any longer
or calling the dispatcher but I wasn't
it wasn't clear to me that uber was
necessarily gonna win the space I mean
the last thing he says is it's important
sorry it's kind of long it's important
to think about what you are well-suited
for so like if you do some introspection
or you ask your mentor to figure out
what you're good at he goes I believe
that founder company fit is as good as
product market fit and he goes lastly
you could
just a good idea if you can articulate
why most people think of it think it's a
bad idea but what you understand about
it that makes it a good idea so that's a
final test all right so I thought
there's a pretty interesting post yeah I
think it's crazy interesting and I
didn't break this up because I don't
even care about promoting this but so
Goggin biani reached out to me about
three months ago and for trends we did
this thing where he like just give a
talk and people signed up and it was
neat and he was like hey I'm thinking
about maybe I want to launch like a
school or something can I like partner
with you guys and you promote this
course I want to do and I was like yeah
that sounds interesting and so me and
him just start riffing more and more and
I really got fascinated with this idea
ideas like why is it Shawn that you are
good at finding ideas and I was like I
don't know why but I wonder if I could
like give frameworks behind it and so
he's kind of leading the way and I'm
just kind of tagging along a little bit
and so we were hosting this thing it's
mostly him posting with a little bit of
me and it's called the ideation bootcamp
and I put together what I thought was
all these frames works on coming up with
ideas and a few of them that I have
coincidentally I've never read the same
up an article until you just told me are
similar and so a few of them are like I
like to do reverse engineering and so
what I look at is I can go to like a
website and see like how they do it
because to me if I can see how someone
does it it helps me realize what's
possible another one is unbundling so I
like to look at like really big things
like eBay or Craigslist or Reddit and
being like okay if usually if
something's huge it becomes a victim of
its own success and they can't move fast
enough to adapt from an early like
interesting change and so we talk about
like I just made up ways to figure that
out and then I see is there anything
else that's interesting that is related
to that because I didn't realize it that
he kind of actually discussed that um oh
and then another thing that I like to do
and coincidentally the things that I'm
talking about is like he's talking about
we just go in like tactically it's like
how do you look at like he talked about
something that's growing quickly but and
you like hop in on it and that's
actually quite hard and tell me what
what I'm missing here the things that I
really love to do is I like to look at
forums and comments and article comments
and user reviews for apps on iTunes
sakir like what what about parking
this [__] that's like makes them love
something or makes them hate something
and that's what I used to come up with
ideas so what Sam often said was it's
something that's growing quickly early
on that like you think is gonna be the
future well how else do discover those
so so there's two way so what is your do
you discover a platform that's growing
really pop really fast and you go on top
of it I'll give you a perfect example of
this zoom is growing like [__] crazy
right now I think I went from like 10
million users to over like 250 million
users during just a kovat crisis you
know my mom and my auntie use zoom now
because that's how we celebrate
birthdays during cocoa and they you know
soom used to be this enterprise thing so
zooms growing like crazy I had this
friend Victor I don't remember if I've
mentioned this on the podcast but he
created this thing called zoom URL
basically zem URL comm and it's
basically Eventbrite for zoom so you
noticed the problem of like hey cool
everyone using zoom to meet up but zooms
like kind of invite and like you know
the sort of like splash that page
doesn't exist so there's not a cool way
to like make an invite for a zoom event
you just send this ugly link and you say
join this zoom that's where we're gonna
do this conference or this birthday or
this whatever and so he just made a
really pretty auto generator you put in
your zoom link and then you can upload a
photo you can put the details all over
and you make this little landing page
for your event and he's growing like
crazy because he's just throwing he's
piggybacking on top of zoom very
opportunistically on the platform and
he's doing something that you know zoom
probably isn't gonna get around to doing
for a little while so he's got this
opportunity to grow solving a new
problem and so the other way which I
said this is I think where I see you do
this less is about technology shifts and
I think this is where gentleman is
actually talking about more which is you
know when you go in the back of an
existing product a platform kind of
sucks cuz you end up with this platform
dependency and then they can often kill
you or clone you or you just get stuck
on that platform you never get off
whereas technology shifts like oh [__]
we couldn't do this before but now
machine learning is good enough that
this is now possible or for example my
friend told me about these little NFC
stickers you know what that is
near-field communication so basically I
bought these on Amazon they're like
these tiny little stickers that cost
like you know 10 cents each or something
like that and if you get these in bulk
they're very very cheap and you just
program them so that like if somebody
just moves their
phone into this thing it touches taps
this thing it's like Apple pay it will
fire something open on their phone you
can open up a website it can open up
whatever and I'm like dude this is great
for marketing like I should just put
these on products or you know this could
be in my shoes it could just say is this
a real Jordan or is this a fake these
little things can be embedded everywhere
because the cost has come down and the
reliability has come up and the core
platforms like I found an Android now
you know by default will react to these
and I've seen things just like they do
QR codes so there's a so technology
ships is I think the one that most
people don't understand cuz they don't
have Technic like technical literacy so
they don't know what's going on and they
don't know when something before that
was impossible is now possible because
it was like actually there's just a
subtle shift over time or the cost of
this chip has dropped and now it's
really economical to do something that
before that would have been ridiculous
or now that you have a small that needs
to be so so how do you identify this so
for example I I have a meeting every
week with my former CTO for my startup
cuz he lives in that like bleeding edge
of technology and I have an hour a week
that it's called the cool [__] hour it's
on our calendar and he just shows me
cool [__] and I just told him look when
we're usually in meetings I talk 90% the
time you talk 10% cuz I'm the kind of
talker or sales guy but in this meeting
you're gonna talk 90 I'm gonna talk 10
and the cool [__] hours just you demoing
to me cool [__] that I don't know about
because I don't understand
cryptocurrency the way you do I don't
understand VRA or the way you do I don't
know about these other ladies are the
technological shifts that are going on
so we've been doing this for a month now
and it's [__] awesome
I basically got a front row seat of this
and all I had to do was just ask a smart
guy who is in that world but the more
generic way of doing that is just to
hang out with those guys so again it's
sort of like what this post was if I was
like who do you hang out with ends up
being what's in your what's in front of
your eyes and so we hang out with a
bunch of business people that figure out
different ways to make money so for us
how do you make money is there some
question of which way do you want to
make money
I know 100 paths and I have a five
examples of each of those hundred paths
I have 500 different examples of how to
make money I just got to choose one that
fits me whereas people who are in the
world of technology they don't really
know exactly how to make money but they
can tell you 100 interesting things with
technology and so sometimes you got to
hang out with them and eat lunch with
him you know three times a week so that
you're hearing those things put yourself
in that position
yeah it's like you just gotta hang out
like in the fringes and I think that
like a great places great places to hang
out the fridges are ready
reddit hacker news just like the way
that it and I guess you've just gonna
you're helping me
finalize my one slide show I have to do
which is you have to look at user
behavior and you have to find this
fringe behavior that's growing quickly
right you know a couple podcast ago I
went off on this random tangent about
defy decentralized fun you know finance
yeah it was just like you know I'm
speaking gibberish I don't even know
what the [__] I'm talking about but it's
because I discovered this fringe right
so all this activity happening I was
like global whoa I don't even understand
this but I know enough to know that this
is unusual and this is a phenomenon and
I need to know more and so like boom
save that tap in that tab open in my
brain and I'm gonna come back to this
you got to know more about this this is
unusual this is new it's interesting
well I think that's what you have to do
when you have ideas which is you have to
actually steal from a lot of different
places so you like take like [__] I
don't know like wow at a restaurant I
could order like I only have to pay for
what I order or something or I don't
[__] know like our giving example
maneuver like I don't actually have to
like have I don't have to own the cabs
you know what I mean I'll give you an
example so two ideas if you if you do a
little idea sex with them so cloud
kitchens we've talked about that in the
podcast before so creating a virtual
restaurant selling on top of post made
to coober et cetera and then in the
world of e-commerce I was thinking about
upsells upsells is you know obviously
critical to e-commerce it's like you're
buying one thing it's like hey do you
want fries with that right hey do you
want this extra thing and it increases
the order value by 20% 30% 40% whatever
it is upsells are critical in e-commerce
in the world of delivered food delivery
they basically don't exist so I was
thinking like how many times were if we
were ordering you know Chinese food or
Mexican food or whatever through some
restaurant why doesn't a breeds just do
a you know sort of have a cloud dessert
company that's always just like do you
want to add some ice cream on top of
that or hey we just made brownies
whatever and like I bet they can
increase the cart size and it shouldn't
be another restaurant it should be a
upsell across all orders of all
restaurants that day then so like I
don't know
you can sort of mismatch ideas if you
see something that's interesting or
critical in one area in another area
they don't do it that's usually you know
makes for an interesting [__] thought
experiment i i completely agree with
this i when i'm wondering is do you can
you teach people this or either got it
or you don't know for short teach people
this yeah i would love to say here
either got it or you don't that would
make it mean that make me feel awesome
because like i got it and other people
do but the reality is i didn't have it
and now I do and I know exactly what I
did to get there I hung out with people
who have a bunch of interesting ideas
and I got thirsty for that so I started
hanging out with them either in person
or my Twitter feed is just full of those
people like I don't have you know I
don't put sports into my Twitter feed as
much like I surround my feed with that
so that even when I'm just browsing
that's what I get the second thing is
like start to come up with these
frameworks so for example one framework
I have you should steal for your thing
it's like you if you imagine this 2x2
grid on the left side you have what type
of problem is this this is a new problem
or an old problem right old problem
people trying to meet their mates they
want to date somebody that's an old
problem new problem hey I'm trying to
throw a zoom event and I don't have a
good way to share that right that wasn't
a problem that existed five years ago
but it exists now and so new brought an
old problem and then you have new
solution old solution so it's like cool
old solutions to things can be applied
to new problems so that's what the zoom
URL thing is he's taking an old solution
like Eventbrite or splash that or like
these proven methods he's just saying
cool I can specialize and tailor that to
this new problem which is zoom events
rather than in-person events and then
you take new solutions which are things
like oh wow so crypto lets you have
trust or like a digital contract so I
don't need an escrow person so maybe you
know I can take an old problem like you
know escrow and a home and a home sale
but an inert solution notarizing yeah
notaries okay cool yeah exactly so a new
solution
push a button somebody has GPS on their
phone and they come to you and they
solve your problem for you they either
pick you up to take you somewhere or
whatever cool maybe I can apply that to
this old problem notary and so you just
take that 2x2 grid and you say cool what
are all the new solutions that are
interesting to me and the other one is
what are all the new problems that are
interesting to me
you just keep jotting those down anytime
you
you know whatever that is and so that's
a framework you can use to understand
ideas and figure out is this idea
actually something novel or not
well it's novel whenever you cross old
problem and new solution or old solution
and new problem
those are the two boxes that the new
ideas coming if it's an old problem old
solution there's nothing new there don't
do it you're blowing my mind I'm
listening
no I don't understand how you come up
with these likes like you think you
think and like you know how people used
to say Obama talks and like quotes like
he always like he just has these
one-liners that are like really great
you talk and frameworks yeah I don't
know why but I think it's because I like
frameworks so I'm studying them and then
I just naturally start thinking that way
another another way to practice this if
you want to become an idea person is
like James altra shared this but he was
like every day I write down ten ideas it
doesn't have to be good bad it's just a
daily practice of idea generation
because if you think about it like oh
man I wish I was better ideas cool do
you do that
do you practice coming up with new ideas
every day oh you don't okay you know I
also wish I was fit but if I don't go
exercise that what what do I expect is
gonna happen well that's gonna magically
get fit it's the same thing here I have
to that idea I don't do the James altra
one but the two I do
one is this podcast twice a week I get
up in front of them you know a lot of
people and I try to come up with new
ideas that's a practice how do I prepare
for that I have these documents on my
phone and my laptop once called the
biggest idea in my head and I have every
month and I just write down it this
month what is the biggest idea in my
head and I just put it there and so like
I'll go to my doctor right now I'll read
you one of mine biggest idea man Sean
everyone has asked that you share this
[__] and you never have yeah you know
these are I I don't know if I want to
share these things today somewhat
something I want to share somewhere they
don't want sure so like in April I
refinance my home and the biggest idea
in my head was like holy [__] that was
so much work and such and so painful
biggest idea in my head is turning
refinancing into a five minute online
process I don't know how but if there
was a new solution that's an old problem
that I would want solved when we were
doing the weight loss challenge the
biggest idea in my head was
holy [__] everybody needs a little
monitor in their body that tells them
how their body is reacting to the food
they eat if we want to change people's
diets and not have half the country be
obese we need to have real-time feedback
loops so that when you put that you know
piece of chocolate in your mouth you pay
a price immediately and not like five
years down the road and so the biggest
idea in my head was how do we make these
glucose monitors so cheap and readily
available that everybody gets feedback
for everything that it'll help the
country eat better about the world
world's eat better that's the biggest
idea in my head for one month and so I
just write these ideas down and then you
know I basically have a place to put
them
I I'm I'm just I'm like being a listener
right now I am thinking about this I
don't know I don't have anything to add
I feel like I'm a student at the moment
it's listening to this but that's great
what you guys are doing if you guys are
gonna release these courses or classes I
don't know I don't know I like really
the truth is is that we don't have
hustle con revenue in June and he had
done all the work and I was like yeah
okay well well I'll work with you had to
do it and I don't know I personally as a
business like our business like we have
an ambitious goal to build a really
large company I think horses will not be
part of that you there right I think
that it was simply like a thing to like
well let's just try it and it actually
covered our also found revenue so or
profits so but we I will not do this I
will not do it ever I hate the course
business I think it is it is not fun but
I it for a solopreneur yeah for a
company no I think it's [__] I think
that if you're reforged which is a
$5,000 thing for companies that is
interesting but I still think it sucks
to host like I don't I don't think it's
like it maybe it make some profit I
don't know if it does but it definitely
does but I personally don't like it
I don't think most people even finish
this [__] yeah most people don't I think
that like Duggan who created he created
what you to me right yeah you know me he
I think he everyone who came out and
said less than 5% of people finish
you know at one point I'm MOOCs
massively open online courses were all
the rage everybody said MOOCs are gonna
revolutionize education it's gonna just
shitty system and then they came out and
they were like look we made a Harvard
education free and open to anyone all
you had to do is click a button and
enroll and then you should got to show
up and take it you could have a Harvard
education for free online from the
comfort of your own home and less than
5% of people I think finish the course
and I think that tells you a lot about
like why people do a thing you know
people don't go to university to learn
that's the sad truth
people go to university to get
credentialed so that they can get a high
paying job so if you want to compete
within the university you should
actually create a credential that gets
you a high paying job that would gives
people confidence if I get this
credential I would get that's I think
this is what you needed this is what you
your next thing will have to be this is
the area I'm most interested in and if I
could just figure out an angle I'll do
it because there's this other great talk
that came from the YC mafia it's by this
guy Richard Hamming and it's called
you and your research she'd go read it's
a speech he gives and I didn't know who
this guy was apparently he's like a kind
of technologist from back in the day he
talks about his time at Xerox PARC in
Xerox PARC was responsible for life
let's call Richard Richard what I think
is Richard Hamming his name I'm pretty
sure is Hamming I don't know if this
person is Richard maybe I just inserted
generic white name but the Xerox PARC is
where like you know the visual graphic
user interface like Steve Jobs went to
Xerox PARC and was like Oh mouse point
set idle on screen that's how computer
should work and he like stole the
innovations basically from there because
they were just doing Rd and he was like
trying to print [__] to the world
anyways he talked about Xerox PARC and
used to he said he tells the stories
like I was that lunch one day and I
asked my co-workers these brilliant
people you know all the brain in the
world is stuffed into these guys skulls
and he's like I asked him what is the
most important what is the biggest idea
in your head what is the most important
problem in your space in your industry
what is the most important problem and
then they would say a thing music and
what are you researching and they would
say a different thing
he's like why aren't you working on the
most important the most burning question
in your space the most interesting thing
in your field why are you that working
on and he discovered like you know so
his his message is basically ask
yourself that question what does the
most the biggest thing in my space what
is the biggest challenge or opportunity
in my industry
why am I not working on it and then she
could work on it he says the filter is
you have to ask yourself do I have a
novel angle and how I'm gonna attack
that problem because if I just go but if
I like the big problems are kind of
known but you need a new attack vector
of how you can solve that problem if you
don't have a new attack vector you're
just gonna waste your time and energy
you're gonna get the same result as
everybody else but if you have a new
attack vector then it is your
responsibility as a smart and talented
person to go to it so that's how I think
about this University thing and for a
long time I already knew the last
project I do I'm gonna do that's
[__] dude that's [__] that is
only one way to do it because if you
think about it like a lot of great
restaurants aren't particularly really
novel in the solution well I mean
they're like novel and branding or
they're novel in that sean is making it
do you know what I mean so I think that
is a little [__] I know restaurants
are [__] right like no they're not
you're wrong
the restaurants are having businesses no
you're wrong one of the large tool min
42 owns what's he owned forty demos but
he also owns some restaurants yes you
know some chains it's mostly he owns the
Golden Nugget me owns a whole bunch of
other stuff too yeah and like some steak
houses is like Bubba Gump shrimp just
like fast casual stuff that regular
people go to and it's like so fun into
the most profitable privately owned
companies America the best restaurant
chains all had a new attack vectors
right McDonald's realized the new attack
vector and they productionize fast food
and they had a real estate model the
franchise model to back it up
Chipotle now and they did the same thing
but they had they realized over the
fast-casual model which was different
but there are many hey there are many
cases where the the amount of success
they had it's not into proportion to the
amount of mmm the their new novelty is
not a proportion with the amount of
success that they have yes so okay
here's what I think if you're talking
restaurants the analogy there is like
I'm gonna create an online course -
right that's me opening up my restaurant
just like everybody else has a
restaurant but my restaurants run by me
I think I'm a good cook I think some
people will like my will like my my
restaurant
what I'm try to do is sort of change
like change the restaurant industry
right so like when I talk about
education it's not like I'm just trying
to create a course I'm trying to make it
so that I guess that here's the analogy
I don't want to build a car I want to
build a road so roads basically are new
platforms that anybody can create a car
on and you can get a lot more data - no
I understand roads versus if you're just
trying to build a car if you're just
trying to be a car driving on the
existing road system you know I mean I
get it
that's a fair point no it's asked is a
car it's us getting on here and
entertaining people we're gonna reach a
certain set of people given a certain
amount of effort making go they can
scale pretty big because we're using the
Internet and it's awesome and it's free
that's that's good it's better than the
cars of old where we would just go to a
event and we would host a meet-up in 40
people would show up and we would talk
that's the old way this is much better
right so much better car but it's still
not a road a road is podcasting if you
create something like podcasting boom
you've changed yeah you've really
changed the world and that's that's more
exciting to me I get it
I we're in the same page there on that
one I think we had an interesting
podcast I'll be interesting to
interested to see if people like it or
not I think we turned I think we covered
a lot and actually turned I was
expecting this week's [__] those in a
horrible mood I think we turn it into
something good cool yeah this was fun I
think we should switch the order around
I think you should put the maybe the
political stuff at the back I don't know
we'll see
well we listened to the reviews we
listened to the tweets so let us know
what you think cool all right let's get
outta here
you
[Music]